okay
so let's start where we left in the last
lecture which was uh a gentle
introduction to operator learning right
so this is where we focused last time
operator
learning and the idea was that if you
have a PD so you could also think of O
stochastic differential equations
whatever you have it but if you have a
PD with some inputs and some outputs you
can express the PD or this so you can
sort of manif the PD in terms of what is
called solution operator and this is
going to be a mapping between two
function spaces so it takes a function
input let's say a and F from the Space X
and it goes to a space Y which is the
solution so the key here is everything
is functions so let's remember that we
are dealing with functions and not with
vectors okay but of course uh as I said
uh in this generality it is very
difficult to solve the problem we have
to do some approximations the first
approximation what we did is that we
know that F here or a and F these are
sampled from some probability
distribution mu which is a probability
measure on X your input space and then
what we did is that we said that the
dimension of this space is
finite in other words instead of dealing
with the entire problem and its full
generality we looked at what are called
parameterized speeds so the dimension
could be large but it is at least finite
so in that case uh the problem is a
finite dimensional one because you have
three inputs or three types of inputs
you have the temporal coordinate T the
spatial coordinate X and the parametric
coordinate Y and the important thing
here is that y this Dy can be large
right but it's fine so I keep on
repeating that and we did some very very
basic Theory back of the envelope
calculations and what we ended up with
the fact was that if everything goes
well the map is nice the solutions to
the PD are smooth and so on still we are
confronted with this challenge that the
total error this scales as 1 / square
root of n this is the best case right
because of the monal rate and this
implies that we need lots of data lots
of data in the sense that to get error
of 1% which is 10 ^ minus 2 1/ 100 you
need 10,000 samples so this was sort of
our challenge in some sense we need lots
of data and you could say that this was
primarily because of random sampling
which is a good ons in general and it's
sometimes unavoidable particularly if
you in very very high Dimensions but uh
is it something that we could address is
it something that we could improve and
the answer is yes means there is unlike
in image and text so if you think of
images uh you can essentially people
take images right they take pictures
they put those pictures in the internet
they put it into different stock stock
image libraries and these are more or
less randomly taken they're not designed
in any particular manner so it's
reasonable to assume that those kind of
images for instance are taken randomly
so it's it's a genuine aners however
when we're doing like scientific
Computing scientific problems nothing is
done randomly we don't go and randomly
solve a PD for the fun of it I do it but
most people don't so then what do you do
in that case so there is much more of a
design space there's much more of a
let's say structure to the data that we
have and we can exploit that there are
different of exploiting it and uh
without beling the point I just give you
one example just to illustrate that we
could we could work with uh let's say
more structured data and this goes to a
trick as I said this is proposed by some
people here in my lab some time back and
the idea is that instead of doing random
sampling what if you have more structure
in the sampling right so remember that
this Dy it's a it's a if you remember in
the air for problems that we saw this
was like Dy was like 20 dimensional
right between 20 and 50 and in some
other problems in many many engineering
problems this this is not infinite
dimensional by Design because these are
design parameters you can only design so
much so you keep it within some finite
dimensional space so it's 10 20 50 these
are the it's not of the order of
thousands right so in that case what you
can do is that you can use a different
type of training data or you can
generate different kinds of training
data and this is sometimes a useful
trick so instead of doing random
sampling so remember that our
alternative was random sampling this is
in blue what I do here is sampling using
what are called Low discrepancy
sequences now I'm I don't have the time
to give you all the details but the idea
is very very simple and let me try to
explain it through this picture here so
this is just in the unit Square in two
Dimensions 01 squ and let's look at how
random points So Random points underly
the monteal method right so these are
random points they underly the monteal
method for instance and as you can see
so I divide the square into smaller
squares I have 25 of them and the idea
is that if you take random points you
cannot guarantee that these points land
in the right squares means in every
Square there is a point in fact you can
see that this Square there is no point
this square there's barely a random
point this Square there is no random
point this Square this square and so on
so on the other hand there are some
squares for instance this one they're
almost six in the vicinity five or six
in the vicinity that's the whole point
of Randomness right because there's no
structure to it you just take random and
then in the next draw you could get
something else in the next draw you
could get something else and if you have
lots and lots of draws of course you
fill up the whole Square that's the
whole point of Randomness however we
cannot have that kind of um let's say
you cannot have so many random draws we
can have at best one or two so then you
don't fill up the whole Square so what
if I design something of course which is
going to fill up the whole Square while
at the same time being better
distributed in some sense right of
course your answer would be then just
take the center of each square that
would solve the problem right all these
all the squares will be covered but then
you can see that per Dimension I will
have one entry in each Square it's
essentially like the number of grid
points that I will have and that of
course blows up with Dimension so just
imagine that if I have 10 dimensions and
in each Dimension I have five points so
I 5 to the^ 10 and that's too much right
random of course if I draw thousand
points it doesn't matter they get
sprinkled all over so there is a
compromise between uniform grid points
which is what you do in two or three
space dimensions three is almost the
limit of that and random points which is
okay if you have a million dimensions
and if you have infinite Dimensions as
you'll see there is no choice but in
finite but large dimensions let's say 10
20 you could do something else and these
are precisely what are called Low
discrepancy sequences
uh there
is earlier I used to teach much more
about it but there is uh probably no
time to do that so the idea is that
they're Simply Better spread out okay so
I'll give one example of this it's
called soble sequence it's a very
popular one and this are the orange dots
and you orange stars rather and you can
see that they are much much better
spread for instance this place where
there is no random point there is a
soall point uh here for instance where
was this one there's a so so ball point
this one there is a so ball Point um
this one doesn't have a random point it
has a so ball point of course the
sometimes they're not like this one has
no so ball Point even though they have
three different random points so it's
it's also not perfect but it's
relatively better than random points
because these sequences are what are
called equidistributed so that is a
precise mathematical definition that I
don't have the time to give but
essentially these are equid distributed
roughly speaking they have better spread
out even though they don't incur the
curse of dimensionality or they have a
mild curse of dimensionality as you will
see in the next slide and there are dime
a dozen of them there are at least 20 or
30 different types they're very very
easy just like you use so these are
these are behind what are called quasi
Monte Caro so just like random points
are behind Mont Carlo these points are
behind what is called quasi Monte Caro
so if you go to I don't know scipi or
any standard library and you search for
these there are many many different once
I I just showed you two soall and Halton
sequences the one in Orange and the one
in green you don't have to learn so much
about them just like you use a random
number generator to get random points
you can use a quas random number
generator to get these kind of points
and this is a fairly easy easy piece of
code and what is the advantage of them
the advantage of them is precisely given
in the next
slide okay so as long as your map that
you're approximating so remember that
this map here this could be the
field this could be the field U of txy
now Z is the entire thing TX y or it
could be an observable so this is what I
called as L of Y right in this case C
would be y so this could be a field or
observable field would be the whole flow
field around the F oil observable would
be the lift and the drag then as long as
this function has certain structure so
first of all it has to have what is
called a bounded Hardy crous variation
so this is um not that difficult it's
just a integral so your underlying map
let me call it as l so D Dy of L let's
say uh this is D y1 dy2 these are mixed
derivatives okay this Dy D this guy is
going to be finite over Dy this is going
to be finite so it's not derivatives but
it's just mixed derivatives as long as
it's mixed derivatives are finite so
this is morally the hardic Rous
variation the function has to have some
structure the map that you're going to
approximate has to have some structure
it can't be discontinuous for instance
then you can prove very easily that your
total error remember that this is a
familiar quantity for us the total error
has two parts training error
optimization error this we cannot uh but
now this is supervised learning right so
it does not have all the problems that
pins have because uh you don't have this
Square Herm mission of the differential
operator or anything so this is standard
supervised learning and then you have
this hardic variation that comes in so
if it has large hardic variation then of
course the constant blows up but uh you
need a smooth activation function reu
for instance won't work because it
doesn't have mixed derivatives but T
hyperbolic tangent or smoo versions of
reu g g glue and so on they will work
and then the key Point here is that you
get 1 / n okay there's a logarithmic
correction as you can see that there is
a logarithmic correction so if you
remember if you have a random sampling
and this is where the
number random
sampling was the errors if the training
error was small was 1 / square root of N
and here let's say it's um with this low
discrepancy sequence LDS low discrepancy
sequence sampling then the error is
going to behave like 1 / n okay so of
course this required for 1% error 1%
error
this require 10,000 points because one
1% is uh 1 over 100 this on the other
hand requires 100 points so it may not
seem much 1 /are root of n 1 / n but
when you do the math you really get a
lot of benefit you know so if each
sample takes about 10 minutes or 2
minutes to generate like we did for the
F foil factor of 100 is quite a bit of
Saving right me it's so and in 3D it's
even much more much more serious so so
this is an example where this problem
with large data the the fact that you
need lots of data as long as you in this
parametric setting and if you have
reasonable number of parameters then
it's okay but of course eventually this
has this is a good part right the one /
n This this term is good but that just
like there's a denominator there's also
a numerator and this numerator is this
logarithmic term here and this is the
bad one because this depends on the
underlying Dimension actually they
should have been D of Y but I'll correct
it in the slides right so of course if n
is
a, log n is just three means there's
nothing but 3 to the power something
right once the dimension starts kicking
in this becomes a serious thing so let's
say that there is a cut off for this and
the cut off is roughly 50 Dimensions
because Beyond 50 Dimensions you don't
have a choice okay so at least for some
of these problems this is going to be
very very useful and I'll show you an
example but so far is this clear how
this sort of by better spreading out uh
the sampling points and we can do that
because we are not taking images we are
not trolling data from the internet text
Data from the internet but we have the
capacity or the power to generate data
because we can we can always generate
data through numerical simulations we
can do it in a much more targeted manner
so this is roughly the model of the
story here and once you have that then
of course you can you can go and try to
solve the problem so if you remember
what I started out with so this was this
problem with the flow past an air foil
um so here is the air foil this is
parameterized with I think 20 parameters
so Dy is equal to
20 and then what we looking here is so
this is the what we predicting is the
whole flow field so we can also predict
the lift and the drag these are the
important observables as you will see
later on uh and then we have a very very
small this was done some years ago so
that is you'll see towards the later
half of the that will end up with um
dnns which are hundreds of millions of
parameters right but for these kind of
simple problems you don't need such big
networks simply not enough data to train
them right so here you just have
something like 10,000 parameters perhaps
I don't remember the exact configuration
now it was maybe 10 layers with or five
layers with 100 parameters in each layer
something like that nothing nothing big
and you have very few training samples
128 this is reasonable you don't you
don't you could afford to have 120
training samples and uh to generate
these samples this was done with a very
very high accuracy because as you can
see the shock here is very very sharply
resolved all these regions are very very
sharply resolved so there is a grid that
is very fine and then of course it took
it takes time it takes about 40 minutes
on a on a laptop this could be speeded
up if you do things in parallel but let
me give you the raw numbers here so it
takes about 40 minutes if you don't want
a a very fine resolution you can get
about in 1 to two minutes okay this is
sort of but this is a very fine
resolution this is the ground Ruth and
then uh you can see that for the lift
and the drag we could get very very good
results 1 to 2% even for the whole flow
field we could get to 1 to 2% results
right the training you generate
the 28 samples this is some additional
cost means we don't count that but once
you start training at that time it's
faster now because the machines are much
faster it took AC approximately an hour
okay whether you took the lift or the
drag or the whole field it took
approximately an hour and the point is
that You' got very very low errors which
is which is good this also looks quite
okay not not exact as you can see that
this is this region is not completely
well resolved but of course this an
approximation this is where the 1% error
comes from but the most impressive
number is what you see
here right so remember that the
underlying simul took me 40 minutes if I
wanted to predict the lift and the drag
which are the real quantities of
Interest here it would take me 40
minutes because I have to compute the
flow field then I have to compute some
integrals these integrals will take me I
don't know 10 seconds to compute that's
not the problem it's the flow field that
takes a lot of time right so you compute
the flow field and then you do the
evaluation and this takes you 40 minutes
but once you have the train neural
network it takes you no time because
this was like not even 10 micros seconds
right 10^ minus 5 seconds for the whole
field it took a little bit longer but
it's still of the order of 1 over 100 1
over 10 seconds it's sort of whole field
means you have to fill in every single
point drag and lift you just have to
give one number so this shows you that
uh in principle if you're able to train
so these these kind of new networks or
models these are called what are called
soret let me write it I don't think I
even wrote it down anywhere so these
kind of models are called sorogens
because they are surit for the entire
physics here the Dynamics here right and
the advantage of this is that you get
very very fast uh quick quick
evaluations of course uh but this was
done the reason why it worked in some
sense was this was done with LDS with so
ball points so ball sampling
points this was a point that I wanted to
illustrate right if I did random
training then of course the errors will
add
because remember that the errors dek
with 1 /are root of n in particular the
drag was useless right if you have 23%
drag you can't do anything lift was okay
lift is somehow easier it's more linear
in some sense drag is much more
nonlinear you'll see in a some some sort
of the whole distribution of lift and
drag in a minute so this tells us that
the method Works provided that you able
to confront with this data challenge
right so if if you needed if you if you
wanted 1% for the drag then you probably
had to take 10,000 samples or 100,000
samples if you remember that this this
error Decay very very slowly whereas
there here with the soall points it was
decaying linearly at least and there are
some problems for which you can do
quadratic or even hyp quadratic and so
on but this is beyond the scope of my
lectures today yes absolutely
yeah that is a
yeah mon yes so that is a huge
difference because and the difference
arises from the fact that there is
theory behind it so you understand also
why this difference arises this this
difference this difference is precisely
due to this Factor here okay good thanks
for the question and now so the the
bottom line is it works provided that
you have this data challenge you have
parameterized everything properly you
have good training data and so on and so
forth now once you have this Sate what
can you do with it right you just don't
stop here that you make a prediction you
do something Beyond some Downstream
tasks okay and the first Downstream task
that you can think of so let me even
write down these are called down stream
so
prediction is just one part of the
problem in Engineering in particular you
don't just predict something you know
you want to do something with it you
want to design you want to optimize you
want to control
you know that there are some end results
some end goals that you want to evaluate
and this is done these are what are
called Downstream tasks and here is a
very simple Downstream task it's called
uncertainty quantification okay
uncertainty quantification roughly
speaking there are this this is a topic
by itself it's a huge topic by itself
with lots and lots of books that are
written on it but the way I think of
uncertainty quantification to explain it
in one slide is that you want not just
one particular value but you want the
whole distribution okay you want error
bars so if you if you think of it all of
you might have done experiments gone to
the lab and so on and then you need
error bars because every experiment has
certain uncertainty and there are there
are some error bars so what are the
error bars in this particular in this
particular point right so for instance
in this um example so this is just a
flow past an air foil similar example to
the one that I have now you know there
there when you manufacture there could
be some small impurities in the shape
right because the shape is never FB it's
never perfectly manufactured but at the
moment we're not even considering that
but the point is that here the
uncertainty comes in from the fact that
you have some flow right so there is
some incoming flow so you make some
assumptions on incoming flow and these
assumptions are based on what is the
incoming pressure what's the incoming
Mark number what is the angle of attack
the angle of attack is where the flow
hits the a foil it's typically one
degrees but it's of course not exactly
1° it's it could be 1.1 de it could be
0.9 de similarly the incoming Mark
number I don't remember now it's
probably 0.8 but of course who says it's
0.8 it could be 0.78 0.82 and so on so
there is a there is a distribution so in
other words inputs to the PD
inputs have some let's say that there is
some uncertainty in the inputs in this
particular case these are the parameters
also could be in the shapes right so
because this Yi they are uh they they
belong to some space Y and there is a
measure on y let me call it as new
because this is not a measure on the
function space it's a measure this a
probability measure on
Y and you generate the samples so the
uncertainty comes in from the fact that
you cannot be precise with your inputs
inputs have some uncertainty in them
okay now once you have this uncertainty
in your inputs of course you have an
operator so you have some uncertainty in
the output right so in other words this
uncertainty in the input is what is
called so what is uq or forward uq
because there is also inverse a base in
uq as some people call it so uq is
essentially roughly speaking very
roughly speaking will be the statistics
of the measure so you have your operator
L and this is what is a push forward
okay in other words if you have some
input uncertainty how does the solution
operator translator propagate it's also
sometimes called uncertainty propagation
how is this uncertainty propagated uh by
the solution operator right so here is a
typical example so you have this
uncertainties in the flow condition
conditions and then uh as you can see
well we have to quantify that
uncertainty the histogram of the lift
for instance this is in blue here so the
histogram tells you that the lift uh is
distributed there is a distribution so
sometimes you can have very high lift
1.2 even sometimes you can have very low
lift 0.8 but it's mostly like a
truncated gaussian with the values
around
0.8 okay so that's that's good so that's
where the lift is so but there is a
distribution to the LIF and this
distribution comes in because of the
uncertainties in the flow okay so in
every physical system that you have
there are some intrinsic uncertainties
and these uncertainties they can be
modeled you can model the input
uncertainties so here we model the input
uncertainties with a prior which is a
uniform distribution well what else
right but if you look at the drag for
instance even though the uncertainty in
the inputs these were the flow
parameters as I told you angle of attack
Mark Mark number and so on uh the the
the so in the lift you get some sort of
a gausian behavior in the drag you get a
very very non-gaussian behavior and this
is because it's a nonlinear problem
right so the inputs are getting
translated or transformed into something
which is highly nonlinear so there is uh
there is that element here and you can
see that this is this is much more of a
what some people call a beta
distribution probably or it's it's sort
of a very very Peak distribution most of
the drag is around
0.6 but there are some extremities when
the drag can be 0.1 then that object
essentially cannot fly if the track is
0.1 and the lift is 0.4 the lift to
track ratio is four No No Object will
fly you need a lifto drag ratio of
approximately 100 or something to fly
but this can happen right if there are
some extreme flows flow conditions then
you you cannot do anything about that
right so the idea is to propagate this
uncertain and how is it done in this is
the same with the weather so when you go
to meet yourtz you open your app and you
look at the uncertainty of weather How
do they calculated so they have some
inputs to the weather right so these are
the temperature at this at this time the
pressure the precipitation all all kinds
of different parameters all and they
know that there is some uncertainty in
that because when they do the data
simulation there is some uncertainty
they run the weather forecast I don't
know how many ensembles they run now but
some years ago it was 50 ensembles so
they would run 50 ensembles where the
forecast is very expensive to run it
occupies quite a bit of time at cscs at
the big superc Computing Center here and
then what happens is that you you take
50 members of The Ensemble or 100
members of The Ensemble and then you
compute the statistics and you get some
uncertainty okay it's a little smarter
than that but morally speaking that is
what is going to happen here but now 100
is nothing remember this is Monte Carlo
sampling at the end of the day and 100
samples the error is one over square
root of 100 as square of 100 is 10% so
it's not you can have large errors so
you need lots and lots of samples again
in order to be able to compute this
uncertainty sorry let me
get so now if you need uh th000 samples
or 10,000 samples how do you do it as I
said the weather forecast was run many
many times right now running the weather
forecast is expensive so you cannot do
it 100 or a thousand times the same here
remember that for a high resolution
simulation it took me 40 minutes but for
low resolution simulation it would take
me 2 minutes and if if I do thousand of
these or 10,000 of these again I'm not
in business right because it takes takes
forever so what we're going to do now
and this a very simple algorithm is once
you have so this L star here so remember
that Monte Carlo sampling you could also
do it with quasi monal random points uh
quasi random points right like soall and
Halton and so on but essentially what
you could
do is that you just this is a mon Carlo
so you take um this is written in some
mathematical mutation but essentially
what is going on is that you take M
samples of the input you propagate you
run your code M times and you average
them so that is going to be the you
average and you compute the statistics
right but instead of using this you
train you take some samples you train
your neural network okay because now
with 100 samples you can train your
neural network quite well we have
realized that and then remember that
then I can take this m could be 100,000
I don't I don't care because for
instance for the lift and the drag it
was one 10 microc right so even if I
take 100,000 samples I still am in one
second because that's the training is
taking its time there's no there's no
choice about that it it takes you some
time to generate the samples it takes
you some time to train them but once you
do the inference it's very very fast so
it's the same here means if you would
have done a direct forecast you would
have taken 10,000 samples which would
take you x amount of time to trade x
amount of time to run now I say I run
100 right it takes time 40 minutes let's
say or let's say 10 minutes for each
sample you can parallelize it that's not
a problem because these are sample
independent but nevertheless it takes
time but once it is there it takes one
hour to train and then to infer it takes
me no time whatsoever right so this is
sort of the algorithm it's more or less
online and then if you if you look at
the speed up first of all the results
are very good because of course your
surrogate has been trained very
accurately so there is little scope for
errors and you can't really distinguish
between the probability density
functions the PDFs the histograms in
this particular case that you get from
the from your sorites and from your
um from your ground fro in this
particular case from with the mon Carlo
the Quasi Monte Carlo run so in fact if
you just looked at the uncertainty using
Monte Carlo
not training with mon Carlo just the
original uncertainty quantification
using Monte Carlo you get two two orders
of magnitude sometimes you have three
orders of magnitude but in this
particular problem you get two orders of
magnitude speed up and this includes the
sample generation time because otherwise
I could have just used those samples to
do my uncertainty quantification right
so I in one case I generate all my
samples I and then I do my uncertainty
quantification in the second case I
generate a few samples do my training
and then do my inference and uncertain
quantification so what is the speed up
that I get if I would have used Monte
Carlo as my base algorithm for UNC
deification these are very very
impressive numbers but of course we know
that Monte Carlo is not optimal the real
test is what if I would have used quasi
monal as my as my algorithm here for the
for my base algorithm even with that
there is a speed up of one order of
magnitude so there is a there is a speed
up it's more modest because you're using
a state of that uh um let's say
algorithm for certainty quantification
but even then a factor of 10 is nothing
to laugh at and this is for this
particular problem in 2D in 3D the speed
ups are much much more so the point is
as soon as you can do this Sate training
there's something cool that you can do
with it right there's something good
Downstream that you can do with it and I
think one of your exercises if I don't
remember has this has this element in
okay are there any questions here no
everybody understood this was a very
very quick uh introduction to
uncertainty
quantification because yeah we have more
interesting things to do in some
sense okay so let me show you another
Downstream task which is even more
vital and this is what is roughly called
as PD constraint
optimization
okay so what is PD constraint
optimization so this is design
essentially and let me instead of giving
you a very General picture of the whole
thing let me give you a concrete example
because it's very easy to communicate or
convey what's going on with this very
simple example and this would be the
problem that we started with which is
the shape optimization of
efforts and the idea is always that
you're going to do this optimization in
order to increase or improve the
aerodynamic properties right because
this is an OP more optimal air foil is
someone which has better aerodynamic
properties okay so what do you do in
this particular is so remember the way
we set the problem up was so we have
some reference air foil this is how
people do this in Boeing or Airbus or
any dasu or any company this is this is
this is the process it's just a toy
version of okay so you start off with
some reference shape U which is given in
Black here this is um some standard
shape that people have uh let's say
realized through intuition you know
because you don't start with a square
and then try to optimize it to airil we
know that a square or a circle plate is
not going to fly so you have to start
with some something which is
aerodynamically reasonable right and
then you start with this and this is my
reference shape and then roughly
speaking I'm going to perturb this shape
I have this design envelope I'm going to
perturb this shape by using what are
called some hick and basis functions
okay these are some splines you can
think of them as some sort of splines
these are usually as I said means my D
is or D Bar actually in this particular
case is anywhere between 20 and 50
because I also need to manufacture them
it's it's uh it's important to
manufacture this right I don't need to
give you the details but what I can tell
you is that all the shapes will have to
lie within this design envelope because
that's what this spans right you can't
have arbitary shapes you don't you don't
want to parameterize this air coil into
a circle you only want to sort of
parameterize it into reasonable
aerodynamic shapes and these have been
designed with a lot of intuition because
people have been designing aircraft the
first air that the right Brothers design
didn't have any of this they just went
and they flew something but these are
bicycle mechanic mechanics trying to
sort of uh do fly an airplane they
didn't they don't didn't need to design
it like that but today modern design you
have this intuition that has been built
in for 100 years and then you go through
this process right and then what you
need to do is to find these parameters
this yis such that I have some air foil
shape for instance the typical objective
function is to minim you fix left
because you want the plane to fly so you
fix
left around the reference air foil lift
so the reference air foil has been
designed to fix lift but then you
minimize trag in other words you take
the lift it's a constant and if you
divide by the drag this lift to drag
ratio it increases right so this would
be another another design objective so
mathematically the objective is very
simple you have an objective function
the objective function has several
elements the first element of course is
the why do I have a pink my children
they play with this all the time so this
is a essentially the drag the drag
coefficient CD uh for each shape we have
the flow conditions that are fixed these
are the cruise conditions that I just
told you we want to minimize the drag
right but we want to keep the lift
constant so this is the lift
coefficient okay this is the lift
coefficient and this is the reference
left we want to keep it constant so we
have some penalty parameter which is
let's say 1,000 1,000 means that I
really
penalize strong deviations from the left
and similarly I these are what are
called structural conditions
structure what do I mean by that at the
end of the day I need to manufacture my
aoil so what happens is that uh just
imagine that the your shape the shape
that you're designing should have some
structural stability and the way in
which aerodynamic Engineers aerospace
engineers measure this structural
stability is that they would like to fit
a beam with certain structural
properties inside the air foil so that
it can't compress too much okay so these
are some structural conditions they can
be there so let's say there are
constraints on the area of the air foil
it can't it can't become too t tapering
it can't become too light in some sense
okay so these structural conditions uh
they are also expressed in terms of
penalization you want to retain some
structural stability you want to retain
lift and within those constraints you
want to minimize tra so this is done
using a constraint optimization
algorithm or penalization algorithm
these are not exact constraints but they
should be they should be kept relatively
constant and then you want to minimize
this now all of you have learned Ben
taught you in the very first lecture
that when you have this is by no means a
convex function okay because there are
this inputs they go into this lift and
drag lift and drag are not quadratic by
any means right so this a non-convex
optimization problem and then what you
need to do is to is to sort of uh
minimize it right so you could use
gradient free optimization some people
use gradient free optimization but the
standard one is to use gradient based
optimization of gradient descent and you
know what gradient descent is so
gradient descent we how many times have
we written it this should be y k + 1 =
to y k minus some learning rate gradient
with respect to Y of J of Y right so you
need gradients so you take the gradients
and you move in the direction of the
negative GR gradient and eventually it
will converge at least to a local medium
now the problem is how do I compute my
gradients okay so now this is the hard
part how do you compute the gradients
you cannot take finite differences
anymore because uh you know you don't
have this grid structure even if you did
because this is a high dimensional space
remember that y is at least 20
dimensional so you cannot take finite
differences in order to compute the
gradients so what people do is they use
what are called adjoint solvers so this
this is a direct problem an adjoint
problem you write a PD for the gradient
this can be done it's a very complicated
PD it can be done and then at each step
you have to solve the PD itself and then
use that to solve that joint PD computer
gradient move solve the new PD compute
the gradient and so on and so forth so
the solving the PD remember that it was
anything between 2 minutes to 40 minutes
ad joint is even more because ad joint
is harder not to crack okay so per step
step it could be anything like 1 hour in
2D in 3D you can imagine the cost
accordingly and you have to do it over
thousands of steps so this is a very
expensive process and the big uh
aerospace companies they they spend a
lot of their compute on this almost all
their compute is spent on these kind of
problems right so that's why I said that
it is either it's very expensive or it
can even be infeasible we take a little
longer maybe before the
break it can be even infeasible
particularly when we doing optimization
on the uncertainty so here I said that
everything is fixed my cruise conditions
are fixed the mark number is fixed the
angle of attack is fixed and so on but
before that I told you that these
quantities these are uncertain right so
there is some uncertainty there and you
want to optimize under that uner so that
will give you additional overheads so
this is this is a hard problem in some
sense and this is the same if you have
cars if you have whatever in shapes any
kind of engineering design this is
precisely the problem that is there
so now of course uh the simplest thing
that you can do is now we know the trick
right we we take some shapes we train
the we have the data we generate the
data from the simulation we drain the
sorate which is the Deep neuron Network
and then simply use the gradients of the
deep neural network neural network all
the gradients can be computed with
backprop automatic differentiation so
this is very easy right so this is
somehow as I said so you just take a
training set this could be random points
or soall points as we know is better and
then you take neural networks these are
going to Output the lift and the drag
and then you just use this as your
objective function instead of using the
the area is anyway independent it's a
structural constraint so instead of
using the CFT simulation which is
expensive what you do is that you just
use the Deep learning surrogate because
you have very accurate ciruit right so
in that case evaluating the gradient is
Trivial we have small networks we do
back prop so how much time can it take
you can even evaluate hens if you want
if you use lbfgs or approximate hens and
then you just run this optimization
algorithm so all your cost is in the
training process once you have done the
training once you have done the tra
generation and your training then of
course the inference is lightning fast
right so it doesn't take any time it's
very very cheap however there is a
little caveat there and the caveat is
very very well expressed by this picture
here
which tells you that now when we train
we we take random points or soall points
these are spread over the entire space
right there is no there's no structure
to these points though in fact soall
points have even been tailor made to be
distributed over the entire space right
that that's over the entire design space
however Optima do not lie at random
places typically Optima lie on some
manifolds and some Curves in the space
and because of that so essentially
roughly speaking if you want to draw a
picture which is what I should have done
instead of giving you this picture but I
prepared it on the train yesterday so so
essentially your training points are all
over the space right something like
this so these are your training points
on the other hand your
optimizers these typically lie along
some curves like this so this is your
optimizers so when you take random
training points the risk is that you are
not approximating the optimizers well
right and because of that of course if
you take enough training points no
problem because then it will fill up the
whole space but if you don't then you
don't approximate optimiz as well and
this has been shown here in this plot
here that uh this is the lift to drag
ratio and if you take 248 points then
you spread and then you see that uh and
you are targeting this region here right
because you want High LIF to drag ratio
so you want to have as high LIF to drag
ratio as possible but if you take 64
points bulk of them because the way
things are distributed they will lie in
this area here and so you are so just
imagine that if you would have optimized
most likely you would have gotten a lift
to drag ratio of 100 which would be half
as effective as the real LIF to tag
ratio which is out there so you're not
able to sort of explore the entire
design space in some sense of course if
you're lucky there is also 120 but it's
still you're significantly
underestimating the Minima and the
Optima in this particular case and this
is the reason why it is happening
because you're not filling the
optimizers well so in this paper I can I
can send you a I can put a link we have
an algorithm that somehow iteratively
constructs this Optima so instead of
taking these points randomly it starts
with a random version of these points
trains the neural networks provides some
approximate Optima takes these as your
random as your new trading points keeps
on iterating so that it better fills up
the space but again I'm out of time time
not space but time so I'm not going to
do that but the point is it's
essentially based on having better
training Al adaptive what called Active
Learning algorithms for this particular
for this particular problem and does
that work the answer is yes at least in
this particular case there are some
other examples in the paper but this one
is very interesting so as I said my
reference drag was 0 essentially 115
units as this is called and after
optimization
uh it was 58 units so you reduce the
drag by factor of almost two that's why
the lifto drag ratio went by a factor of
200 right means it's the lift remained
where it was so it was 87 units and it
remained at 88 units so almost 50% of
the drag was reduced and uh here is the
reference shape and the absolute minimum
as you can see this is a very very tiny
pertubation right the shape itself is a
tiny tiny change and in this particular
case this is a very idealized case you
know in in real air foils uh Wings you
cannot get 50% brag reduction you get 5%
but 5% is 5 billion dollar of in less
fuel because that's at the end of the
day these things have to fly you have to
you have to pay you have to pay for the
aviation F fuel which is very expensive
so this is uh in this idealized case no
human could design this tiny tiny
perturbations right so this is
impossible this is why we do automated
design and in fact if you look at the
comp comparison okay that's nice but
what if the same these These are
impressive in some sense as wrw numbers
but what is much more impressive is if
you take the so this iterative algorithm
not the base algorithm that I told you
with deep new networks so this is the
traditional algorithm it has a name TNC
based on the optimizer but to get the
same results you are in this region here
so this region is
248 forward
solves okay and in comparison you get
something here right so this is like
80 so 804 obols because you need to
train this network and you used 80
simulations to do that that's that's the
way I measure and remember that this is
doubled so it's really 80 and 4,000 so a
factor of 50 you you gain a factor of 50
this was of course proof of concept as I
said means in this particular case there
are many idealizations but with this
algorithm it really work we have some
version of it in 3D but that's that's
more of a detail right but the essential
point is a well-trained neural network
can be the basis for many many
Downstream tasks and just I'll end by
showing you how the flow looks like so
that you have some idea so this is how
the flow looked like on a reference air
foil right so there the most of the drag
is caused by this shock here that's
that's a whole point right but if you
look at the best configuration all that
it did was this you can't there's no
visible difference between the shape
here and the shape here they're slightly
different from each other right but it
did change the characteristics of the
flow quite quite heavily because there
was some tiny the the shock track
reduced and as a consequence of it there
was a 50% reduction and uh the point is
first of all this cannot be done by
humans in some sense second it's
expensive to do it by traditional
numerical solvers and once you have well
trained neural networks they can do it
rather well so you you can do these kind
of Downstream tasks very well and I put
this up front because now I'll not talk
so much about Downstream tasks I'll
Focus almost entirely on prediction
because once you have prediction maybe
if I have time I'll do something on
inverse problems because that's a very
different types of Downstream tasks but
what I'll do is I'll focus on predation
so from now onwards we'll not talk about
on CTIC modification not talk about
shape optimization control but you know
that all these can be done if you have a
very good predictor okay so with this we
are going to stop uh we we reassemble at
quarter past okay quarter past so that
uh we can
have
seconding Okay so let's uh restart so
it's somehow
The Narrative of the course is that we
start with something say that is a best
thing and then demolish it and start
with something else say that it's the
best thing and then demolish it and keep
on doing it and keep on doing it but
that's how science is you know
particularly for a new field you think
that oh this is the best thing but then
you realize ah this is UN for the
investigation that that's not the case
so I explained to you so much about
parametric pdes in the last um one and a
half lectures but now I say what are the
difficulties with it and this will be
the recurring theme that is you'll find
out that this is such a things are in
such a state of flux there's no ultimate
solution yet which is good right because
then there are things to do okay so
what's the challenge with
parameterization so everything was good
now now right so I cheated I had an
infinite Dimension problem and I simply
said oh we can approximate everything in
fin Dimensions but well the difficulties
of parameterization so the first one
which is a very practical one is that um
it's difficult to come up with a it's
very difficult to come up with one right
so remember that these parameterizations
that resulted in these shapes these have
been done with many many T of 10 20 30
years of engineering experience that's
why we were able to come up with
parameterization like that if you're
going to design a little vehicle a drone
of your own means there is no such
parameterization that you can use right
so you have to handcraft it this is this
is this is problematic but there are
even more difficult issues with it of
course needless to say it's not unique
so here is uh and because of that there
are some issues with generalization so
what does it mean that it is not unique
so here is a parameterization which is
exactly two different parameterizations
give you the same answer sort of very
easy to see that so I can have a
function parameterized function
parameterized by single parameter X
which uh essentially realizes function X
squ the quadratic function right but if
I didn't know that this was the case I
could also come up with the following
parameterization y1 is some A1 of x + B1
Y2 is A2 of x + B2 and I can take any of
these uh A1 A2 B1 B2 I can come up with
y1 Y2 and I can rewrite my function
instead of a function from one parameter
to Vector to an output a scale output I
can write it from two parameters to a
scal output and I will here I have taken
half and a half but I could take 1/ 18
and 78 or 1/4 and 3/4 and whatnot so the
bottom line is the bottom line rather
not the bottom line is that there is no
unique way in which you can do the
parameterization so now suppose I wanted
to learn this function and and I wanted
to sort of try I learned this function I
take data from one space Dimension I
train it and of course I can I can
realize the quadratic function but then
someone says okay take uh apply your
method to learn the function from in
this parameters and then you fail
completely because your method takes one
input and produces one output without
realizing that it's exactly the same
function that can be realized by taking
two inputs and producing one output or
three inputs and producing one output or
100 inputs and producing one output
right so this is the issue with
parameterizations that these are not not
unique and because of that they don't
generalized well and this is sort of the
key in machine learning because machine
learning is all about generalization and
if you don't generalize you have not
properly machine learned something so
what does it mean in this particular
context and why do I highlight this so
much so from now onwards I will keep on
sort of harping on this word
generalization quite a lot okay so here
is an example which is uh which is which
is quite instructive in some sense so
this is the same hick H air foils the
way that I told you and here I took an
input dimension of D equal to 20 so this
is how the air foil looked like and this
is very much in the setting that we we
had right so this this this particular
set where is
it this setting 20 Dimensions so you
could generalize there but now someone
would say that okay 20 dimensions you
have trained your neural network to
produce something in 20 dimensions and
this is the ground truth but the neural
network can do a very good job in
approximative that's what we said right
but now for some reason someone came up
with the idea that okay actually there's
a more optimal version of this air foil
which will be here it's more sort of
tapering you know instead of being so
flat may not be the case just to tell
tell the story here so this on the other
hand I cannot parameterize with 20
Dimensions anymore I need 30 Dimensions
because the spline functions 20 spline
functions are not enough to parameterize
it I need 30 Dimensions so this is how
this air looks like so what can you do
can your neur and the flows they are of
course there's a slight difference but
they're not completely different from
each other maybe the as you can see this
is the flow is more or less of the same
type right so in principle
generalization would have meant that my
neuron Network which would have which
which has learned on this shape of air
foils I can apply it either zero shot to
the new configuration or find unit as
some people call it use a little bit of
data and find un it I finished right
because remember what did my neural
network do it took 20 inputs of course
it also took the spatial coordinates as
inputs but that that's the same it let's
say took 20 inputs and produced me the
lift and the dra now suddenly you giving
me 30
inputs what do I do me uh uh I don't
have any training data to go from 20 to
30 even though the air foils themselves
are very very close to each other right
so in principle I should be able to
learn one from the other but because I
use this particular strong
parameterization or strong reduction of
my compression of my information I'm
left with no choice because okay now how
do I go from 20 to 30 I don't know I
certainly cannot do it zero short I need
some mechanism by which I can go from 20
to 30 but then someone will say okay the
mechanism is very simple you should have
started out with 30 parameters and
instead of taking the 20 parameters 20
active and 10 passive parameters that
would have done your job but then
someone else will come okay let's have
something with 40 parameters maybe it's
even more what do you do so essentially
parameterizations are necessarily
limiting because the input remember the
end of the day you had to work with a
function space input because if I had to
deal with functions and just think of
this shapes as function level sets so
these are Level sets of some functions
then this guy here and this guy here
they're close to each other there's not
a huge difference between them but if I
think in terms of parameters they're far
from each other mean they they they not
even in the same uh they cannot even be
compared something is 20 dimensional
something is 30 dimensional and another
way to do it to think of it is just
imagine that if you had a function just
just think of it it's it's a very
intuitive way so let's say I have a
function f okay I can reite this
function as some FIA series let's say
sin KX F series expand the function
right and I take another function g i
expanded GL sin
LX and let us say that
my uh
FK is equal to GK for 1 less than K less
than 20 they have the same uh
coefficients okay so but in one case I
have my K from 1 to
20 and in another case I have my L from
1 to 30 and let's say that GL decays
like one over or exponential to the m
Cell between L and 20 and
30 they are going to be very very close
to each other in some sense so these two
things are very very close to each other
but suppose I would have used my FK as
my parameters and GS as my parameters
for the first 20 parameters they're
exactly the same I would have done
whatever right but as soon as I go for
the whole function even though as
functions they're very very close as
parameters they're not in they're not
comparable at all right because one has
20 and the other has 30 so you see so
this is necessarily limiting it's it's
just a concrete example of this problem
that this is not a natural way of course
it's a pragmatic way it's a practical
way that you write everything in terms
of parameters but it's not a natural way
because there is no sort of connectivity
between the two one one is sort of
disconnected from the other so
unfortunately even though these are sort
of good baselines they can be useful in
certain contexts but in general you have
to stick back to operator learning you
have to work with functions you have to
but we learned some tricks right we
learned that we could use some some
representations we could do some
Downstream tasks and so on so it's not
completely useless but nevertheless we
have to deal with uh with the Beast as
it is we cannot just chop it off into
pieces and the Beast is that you have to
learn the the inputs and outputs are
functions so here is a function and here
is another
function and in the next uh few lectures
we are going to we are going to deal
with that right and this is the operator
that you have okay so this is the this
is the setting again I keep on this is
my abstract PD I keep on changing it
slightly all the time but you you
understand it from Context and the
solution operator so you have to find
now a Sate based on DNN from the data
itself and you have to deal with there
there's no way so we have to do some
sort of smarter reduction to finite
Dimensions because computation have to
be anywh done in finite Dimensions but
we have to do something smart some sort
of a smarter reduction how do we do that
so okay so here's a solution okay that
the cheating was to have a finite
dimensional problem now we don't have
finite Dimension problem we have an
infinite dimensional problem and let me
try to explain this because this is
going to be rather rather gerain to what
we are discussing so let me try to
explain this relatively well so what
what what are we seeing here so we are
seeing a fluid flow so this is the Navia
Stokes equation
incompressible Navia Stokes equation in
2D because most of our examples are in
2D things scale to 3D but of course the
computational challeng is for M but
let's say this is in 2D and what you're
seeing here is a verticity of the fluid
okay verticity is is just the curl of
the
velocity velocity field this is the curl
of the velocity and this is the initial
verticity let me call it as Omega 0 and
this is a verticity at a certain
time as a function of space both of them
are functions of space so as a function
of space so you can see that okay you
start with some vorticity there are some
vertices here some vortices here some um
negative vertices verticity going of be
sign right so negative vertices here in
2D it's a Scala in 3D it's a vector and
that makes all the difference for fluid
flows but the point is then then it
evolves and you cannot have predicted
just by looking at the initial verticity
how the final verticity is going to look
like this it's impossible to predict
there's no formula to write down you
have to this has been done with some
numerical method some spectral method or
I don't remember what's a numerical
method but some numerical method so
essentially I have been given an input
function initially a function and I have
been given an output function and my
time ask is that can I have a Sate can I
learn this function from data I have
some data earlier I used parameters but
now I cannot use parameters any these
are genuinely given as functions okay
images in this in this sense right so
the first solution which is actually a
very trivial and a useful solution is
the follower and let me explain it uh
with some context otherwise because this
is
important the point is I have to do
computations in finite dimensions there
is no way I can do this in infinite
Dimensions so I have to do something in
finite Dimensions so I have to do some
finite dimensional reduction okay this
is how I do my first reduction which is
I use
sampling so I have a function which is
an infinite dimensional object because
this can be evaluated at every Point
what I do is okay I say I cannot this is
numerical analysis right I I
cannot have every single point because I
cannot store every single point on a
computer I take a bunch of these points
a discrete finite set of these points so
in this particular case just visually I
have taken 16 by 16 points 16 in this
direction 16 in this direction just for
Simplicity okay but in in practice
during my training I'll take 64 in each
Direction because I don't want to show
you 64 points so I take 16 by 16 points
256 points in practice 64 by 64 so 496
point so 128 by 128 which is a much
larger number 16,384
but anyway this is uh 16 by 16 points
and I sample the function at these 256
points so instead of having a function I
now have a vector verticity and each
entry is the verticity at these points
so I have a vector which is 256
dimensional 496 dimensional 16,384
dimensional so that is roughly the the
the the scaling that I'm I'm thinking
about right so now my function is
effectively been reduced at the input
level to a vector a large Vector much
larger than the parametric vectors that
we had before so this was the advantage
of parameters right because they were
representing my function much more
compressed manner with 20 parameters
instead of having 256 even in a very Co
grid and much larger when you take
larger grds I can do the same for my
output right my output is also a
function I can sample it to 56 points or
4ou 496 points and so on so essentially
I have just by taking this one very
simple step I've reduced my infinite
dimensional problem which is mapping a
function to a function to a finite
dimensional problem just mapping a large
Vector to a large Vector right so
remember that this problem here instead
is mapping w0 at
XJ J from 1 to capital
n and this is mapping it to
W the Omega rather Omega this is a
vector now right you can put whatever
order you can take the raster order like
what people do in images that's that's
not that important this is at time one
but at Point 6j same points I could take
different points no one stops me but
let's take for simp the same points now
as I said n is the number of points 256
16,384 and so on it sort of starts
scaling in different manner right so now
all that I have to do is I have to now
go just by doing the sampling I've
reduced this into finite dimensional
problem and I can use deep neuron
Network I can I can map between them
using a deep neuron network of course
this will be a very very big Network
because if you have 4,000 yes James um
the the also be seen as pration
like basis something
so it can be seen as a parameterization
except that it is not a fixed paramet
ization because when you change the
number of points the parameterization
also changes right so this is not a
we're not reducing everything to one
fixed set we have a set that can grow or
contract depending on the number of some
points indeed you can think of it and we
will we will see that in a second but
you allow these points to change that's
the whole point in some sense right that
you allow these points to change but
nevertheless the first challenge is that
even if I have 496 points and 496
outputs
it becomes harder to sort of put in a
deep new network because its input
Dimension is 496 output Dimension is 496
so my network would be rather big so
already from image processing image
complet Vision we know that for images
it does not make any sense to take this
fully connected MLPs multi- trums we
should take more structure and this is
where where CNN's come in right and this
is I think you had a lecture right in
the very beginning you had some intr
Rory material at least on
CNN and roughly speaking what they their
convolutions means we are going to see
that in uh later on today but
essentially what you can think of is
that if you remember the neural network
is
essentially um W let's say this the lth
layer um let me call it as okay VL let's
say plus some B right so this is the
weight Matrix this is the bi Vector so
this weight Matrix would have been a 496
by 496 dimensional Matrix if I would
have taken the entire structure a dense
Matrix so this would be a sparse Matrix
right so you have a sparse Matrix
structure because this is what
convolution does it has a very sparse
Matrix structure so it has some non I
there some non-zero elements this is
just a simplification and then it has
some zero elements so this is the
structure of the Matrix so it has a spse
matrix and this is what is shown by this
uh little sort of moving window this
moving window is what hits you and gives
you non-zero values and you keep on
changing it so this here is a
representation of a CNN but you could
take MLP if you have a computational
resources you could take MLP a CNN um
the is a MLP but with some
structure that's that that's all that
you're doing right and then so you have
this mapping between 496 and 496 instead
of a DNN you take a CNN more structure
good and then you get a 496 dimensional
output but remember that my target is
not something which is sample my target
is a function right so I have this
function on 16 by 16 grade uh 64x 64
grade 128 by 128 grade so what I can do
to get it at every point is to use
interpolation right interpolation tells
me that if I have a discrete set of
values I can automatically interpolate
and get a continuous function right so
this is a very very simple way where we
do a finite dimensional reduction and
yet we are able to do the processing in
the sense that I start with a function
sample it on a grid use a CNN this is
one particular architecture I could have
used something
else and then I have values on a grid as
outputs and then I go back to the
function by using interpretation is this
uh scheme clear it's a very very
straight forward scheme in some sense
and the question and then of course our
training our is done at the level of
this grids right so the weights and bies
of this network this WLS they have more
structure than what I'm saying but uh
these are done at the level of this 16 x
16 or 64x 64 grds does it work the
answer is yes to some extent because
just to give you an example I took a
slightly more difficult problem because
this problem is too easy in some sense
we will we'll talk about that later but
this is the same setting so I still take
perhaps this the velocities instead of
the verticity
so it's still nav Stokes uh with a very
high enal number so that it's
essentially approximating inv visit flow
so that interesting things happen and
this is a very well-known problem in
fluid fluid mechanics computational
fluid dynamics which is that you take a
Shear layer can happen here uh in in the
atmosphere so you take a Shear so the
velocities go like this and the
vorticity is concentrated along this
little sh and then vortices are shed so
this is how the solution evolves these
are the velocity evolves the velocity is
this is just the x velocity for
visualization and this is what what
happens to it so I do the training on a
64 square and uh then of course I what I
have is I have a ground grps right so
this ground proo is generated by a
numerical simulation but I can do this
at if I want at 16,384 squar I have the
code and the computer do it but it is
done 1024 squ okay 1024 squ is fine
enough resolution so I have a ground
truth and because I have this function
and this is a question that James asked
I have the freedom because it's a
function right it's not a it's not a
vector so I can evaluate it at 16 squar
32 squar 64 squar 128 squ 256 squ
whatever resolution that you want so I
train it at 64 squ I compare it to the
ground proo at 64 squ and then let's say
that this is your training error or
generalize or test error
let's call it as the training error okay
and this the number that I get is 5%
this is this is neither here nor there
it's some number okay 5% it's it's
satisfactory it does a good job so you
say oh okay good that I really solved
the problem in some sense but this is
precisely the issue that I haven't
solved the problem and why haven't I
solved the problem because remember that
I can evaluate this function at 128
squar or at 96 squar so and I can also
so in so train at 64 squ it's very
important so pay attention I train at 64
squ my weights and biases everything is
trained at 64 squ but my evaluation can
be at different resolutions it can be at
96 squar it can be at 32 squ which is a
function it's not a particular fixed
Vector my parameterization can change
this is the point that I was trying to
make and then of course I evaluate and I
look at the errors I compare the errors
and then you see as soon as I change my
training resolution for instance if I go
to 96 squar then I get an error which is
three times more and if I go to 32 squar
which is a smaller training resol
smaller than the training resolution
there is increased by a factor of five
so in other words I have not generalized
at all I have not train I not learned a
function at all I've just learned one
particular realization of the function
on a grid so this is not operator
learning this is just in some sense
cheating I'm still learning a fixed
parameterization a large
parameterization but a fixed
parameterization because as soon as I
change my parameterization it does not
generalize and here the parameterization
is in terms the sampling right because
as you said this is a this is a
parameterization and this is not my
Discovery or anything this has been
known for a while that you cannot just
learn functions by sampling them on
grins because that is not that is that
that you lose a lot of information doing
that so there is a there's an issue
there because what you learn what you
need toar is the underlying operator and
not just one discrete
representation so this tells you that
there is a there is a little suck here
that you have to learn some equivalence
between the continuous and the discrete
because the function is a continuous qu
it's in the continum whereas vectors
sample points of the functions these are
discrete quantities and there has to be
some connection between them otherwise
you don't learn the function this is a
very very important Point are there some
questions about this particular point
that I made so this graph is what is
somehow absolutely crucial it's it's
very very important because it tells you
that as I said everything is about
generalization so no generalization is
happening in other words uh if you
remember coming back to the F4 example
even though we had uh the possibility of
evaluating on uh on 30 basis functions
the answers will be very bad because you
are simply not generalizing you're
learning only on 20 basis functions so
that's why I keep on I I took my time to
explain this because it's it's very
pertinent to what what I'm going to say
questions no anyone on Zoom who wants to
ask a question about
this okay so this is this is the key
point right so we have not learned the
function we have just learned one
particular realization of it and this is
really a challenge from from various
angles and let me try to explain that so
remember that at the end of the day my
operator my mapping so this is for DC
right this was the elliptic case St C so
my operator is a mapping between the
input and the output right these are
functions these are functions but in
practice of course I have to work with
discrete uh there's there's no choice I
cannot even unless until I use some
symbolic package I cannot even write a
function on a computer I have to
approximate it with something discrete
but the problem is that there are
multiple ways of doing a discrete you
could change the resolution of the grid
you can have grid you can have the same
Grid or you could change the solution as
we did in this particular example or
what can be even more frustrating is
that your input can be on some random
points Point clouds as these are called
outputs can be on point clouds and so on
so there are multiple discrete
representations of the same function the
same function you can approximate at 16
squ 32 squ 64 squ or you can approximate
it with fixed sort of uniform points you
can approximate it with random points
quasi random points and so on all of
these are B Aid day representations of
the function
but at the same time they they have the
same underlying reality but to us when
you look at them discreetly they look
very different even though they
representing the same reality right and
this is where you need to understand
this concept of some equivalence between
the continuous and the discrete you have
to go between the continuous and the
discrete in order to be able to solve
this problem okay so what I'll do in the
next 15 minutes is really try to attack
this particular question how do you link
The Continuous and the discrete so that
you can design architectures Frameworks
which go seamlessly between the two and
this this is mathematic not
mathematically that difficult but it's a
little it's a little subtle so you have
to pay a bit of attention Okay so let us
try to continuous discrete or discrete
continuous equivalence whatever you call
it I should have switched now I made a
mistake here so essentially what is the
problem here the problem here let me try
to explain is that this is is my let's
use some pen here so this is your
continuous world this one here right so
these are function spaces so this is
this guy here these are function spaces
right and your actual operator your
ground root is sitting right here but
because of the way in which our digital
computers operate that will probably
change when you have analog computers
but at least for digital computers we
have no choice but to work with the
discrete so this for instance would be a
grid values on a grid of course this is
values on a grid let me use another pen
and this is your discrete
operator right so this is your discrete
operator so what is important is that
there should be ways of going between
one and the other so this for instance
for sampling I showed you sampling here
I showed you interpolation sampling and
interpolation such that this this
happens simly that when you operate in
the continuous or when you operate in
the discrete rather it's the same as
operating in the continuous because that
that would solve the problem right so
how do we do this this is sort of the
Croc of the
argument and uh let me just continue
this and the framework is very recent
but uh it's sort of is not hard to
understand so what's going on is the
following so at the end of the day to go
between the two you need two elements
okay so let me give them some names I
call them as an encoding
e so this is a mapping between your
function space and your discrete space
so this guy here right this is the
mapping between the function space and
the discre space this could be sampling
on a gr for instance and then you have a
decoding or I I prefer to use the word
reconstruction because it's really not
between vectors of different sizes but
between vectors and functions otherwise
it would have been so
reconstruction so I called it as are
which is mapping the other way around it
goes from the discrete to The Continuous
so this guy okay and uh the same plays
here maybe they are different but just
for Simplicity I took the same okay so
now the point is that the continuous and
the discrete can be related to each
other in a particular manner so if you
think of it now now Focus that this was
a mapping between X and Y one way to
realize this mapping is I go from X to
to this X or caligraphic X to X that's
from The Continuous the discrete with e
so I do this then I do my work here G
and then I go back again by using this
guy here R right so this exactly what we
did before that we could have where was
the picture here that first we went from
the let's say from The Continuous to the
discrete by using the sampling so this
was my e then I did some processing
there this was the CNN this was my
operator G discrete operator G and then
I went back up with the
interpolation okay so this is the
algebraic structure this is the scheme
somehow in how I
operate okay so now what we want is that
these two things should be exactly the
same this is what we want because then
working with the discrete is the same as
working with the continuous I work I do
my all my work at the discret but then
there is something which is going on at
the level of the container right
unfortunately that is not always the
case because if that were the case then
I would not have gotten this picture
here right because then it would have
always corresponded to the same
continuous function but it didn't so the
error in doing this there's a name for
this error means some of you who have
done some signal processing in
electrical engineering probably know
this error so this error is called what
is called
aliasing okay aliasing error is when the
equivalence between the continuous and
discrete so now this this is the way if
this would have been true then there
would be some equivalence between the
continuous and the descript but that
fails then you end up with some error
it's an operator because it acts on
functions and this is what is called the
aliasing error operator which is
precisely the gap between them so this
is the mismatch okay the mismatch
between the continuous and the discrete
I'll give you some concrete examples in
a minute but this is the abstract level
and all that we asked is that this
should be made zero right so this so the
operators the let's say the neural
networks these are called there's a name
for them these are called
representation equivalent or resolution
equivalent but I prefer the word
representation equivalent NE operators
or
Renos all that they do is that these by
construction are such that this error is
equal to zero so they don't Alias at all
okay so you want to construct them
they're not available there you have to
construct them them in such a manner
that there there is no Alias that
whether you work with the continuous or
whether you work with the discrete you
get the same answer okay of course you
can say that maybe in some problems it
is impossible to have an exact
realization of this but at least they
should be small the relasing errors
should be small hopefully vanishingly
small right but now remember that at
neural networks or neural operators as
we are going to call them these are
compositions right so I missed something
here so these are typically compositions
they done layerwise so what we demand is
that uh I don't even know why I wrote
this but this is equal to Z is
identically equal to so we want that
this
sorry uh this was a bit so you want that
for each layer whatever layer that you
in this eling error should be zero but
once you have a composition Z composed
with 0 is z composed with 0 is z so if
every layer of your neural network or
neural operators we going to call it
satisfies this property that there is no
aliasing and the whole operator does not
have any alas so that is that is the
construction and what is the advantage
of this construction and as I said these
objects need to be constructed they have
not yet been there they need to be
constructed but if you are able to
construct them then an immediate
coroller of this construction is the
following that that if you have
different grids for instance remember
that these G's here these are mostly
different this G here is on a grid right
so this you can think of it as on a grid
so you have different grids so one grid
would be called as um G and the other
grid would be called as G Prime for
instance then what happens is that there
is a natural connection between them
what is the meaning of this natural
connection the meaning of this natural
connection is that remember that your
underlying operator capital G and you're
going to approximate with this G
similarly your underlying operator is
capital G the same operator that does
not change what changes is your grid
resolution for instance so you have a
new grid resolution G Prime but you have
the corresponding R Prime e Prime and so
on and these two things they are sort of
related to each other because you can go
from one to the other you can go from g
to g Prime and the way you go from G is
you start with uh G go back to your
function space so this is what you do so
you go back to your function space then
you work with the continuous operator
which works here and then go to the
discrete Again by using this RP Prime
here so this is the construction that is
there and this links G and G Prime the
operator different grids because all
that it says is that okay I first went
from this grid to The Continuous through
this operator and then composed again to
so in other words so we start with uh
let's say let let me take a minute to
explain this because this is important
so I start with this grid let's say 64x
64 uh just for completeness then I go up
to the continuous by using this R this
reconstruction operator so I started
here so I go up to this here uh or I
started here rather and go here to The
Continuous and then I go back to the 128
by 128 grid through this so there is a
natural connection between them and the
same at the output side right and when
you combine them this is what you would
get if this was not zero if there was an
error here then it would automatically
show up because we used to to derive
this expression it's very very
straightforward that I use the fact that
the eling error between these two grids
is equal to zero in other words you
start with one discrete go to the
continuous then come back to the other
dis and when you combine them because
these diagrams these are called
commutative diagrams they commute you
can easily transfer them it's it's it's
rather straightforward and if you did
not have this if this was not zero and
this was not zero there would be
discrepancies because once you go from
the discrete to The Continuous you make
an error and then when you come back
from The Continuous to discrete you make
another error these errors can sort of
couple with each other and give you
large errs of course they could also if
you're lucky cancel out and this also
sometimes happens but mostly by Design
you shouldn't have this you go for so if
you have two different grids you start
with the course grid let's say course
and fine it could be fine and course
also but you start with the course grid
you do the calculations at the
calculations are done there but there is
a continuous analog so essentially what
is happening at the discrete is mirrored
at the continuous level you do that and
then you come back to the final gr so
there's a natural way in which this
transfer happens and I'll give you a
concrete example so if you had this
representation equivalent neural
operators which allows for a seamless
match between the grids then you are
able to do this let me give you an
example and then perhaps it becomes
clearer because what I haven't given you
is what is the function space what is
the encoding what is the Reconstruction
and so on because there are of course
multiple examples of it but the example
that we are going to concentrate on
quite a lot just for Simplicity in 1D
but this can be done in any Dimensions
is by using what called band limited
functions okay so if you just use
arbitrary Square integrable functions
you cannot do this because there's no
way you can marry the continuous and
discret but if you take band limited
functions what are band limited
functions so simply think of it if you
had a fer series for instance so you had
U of X is given by U hat k e of I KX
something like this so that's a FIA
series all that you do is that you work
with a finitely many for modes okay so
that is band limited so you only have
finitely many bands and these are very
very important class of functions
because of course the bands can be large
if you take a thousand frequencies you
can represent quite a lot but the bands
are not infinite right so this is this
is an important point so in that case if
you have band limited functions then the
encoding here between the band limited
functions is given in terms of pointwise
evaluations so you can just take a
function sample it on a grid and then
you can go back by using a interpolation
using what is called the sync basis so
all of you I I hope know what the sync
function is so sorry so
sync where is it sink of X is roughly
sin of X roughly there are some
constants sin of X by X okay this is a
very well defined function very common
in Signal processing and the point is
that you can so the these VJs are my so
the continuous is a function the
discrete is given by point values and
once I have the point values of a
function then all that I do is I can use
the sync to go back to the function okay
so in this case there is a nice match
between the continuous and discrete and
if you have a dense enough grid so this
is uh what is given by the neest barrier
so if the number of grid points are
double that of the frequencies that you
are keeping then there's a bijection
means the continuous and the discrete
are identical so whether you have a
function or whether you have its point
values on a dense grid they are one and
the same and the link between them is
given by by this particular particular
thing so if you if you have this setting
which is a setting that we're going to
use quite a lot a cartisian grid
equispaced with enough points to resolve
the functions that you are approximating
then whether you working with the
continuous or the discrete the answer is
identical okay and this is the neest
Shannon sort of theorem some people call
it this is very common in Signal
processing and you can look up Wikipedia
to see that what what does it imply it
simply implies that if you have enough
frequencies if your function has certain
number of frequencies and if you sample
it at enough Equis space points you can
exactly reconstruct the function okay so
this is the setting that we are going to
utilize and let me very quickly tell you
that based on this setting it's a very
concrete setting we can already prove or
show very simply that convolutions CNN
or MLPs for that matter these are not
representation equivalent because what
are convolutions convolutions are first
you do convolution activation
convolution activation convolution
activation right so if you start with a
discrete convolution so these are
discrete convolutions so essentially I
have
a I have a function C I keep on changing
notation I have a function C and I have
some convolution kernel K and the action
of the kernel is I have a I have fixed
window right so I have a fixed window as
I showed you and I multiply the kernel
functions Shifting the underlying
functions so in other words the way it
happens is that I have a signal let me
call it a c here and then I take a
convolution kernel this is my
convolution kernel which I give here and
then at every step at every iteration of
this kernel I hit a certain number of
values at the next iteration I'm going
to hit these values at the next
iteration I'm going to hit these values
sorry at the next iteration I'm going to
hit these values and so on that that's
what convolution does right you you run
through you slide a window through the
signal now why is it not a Reno in this
particular case the simplest argument is
if you take a finer grid it could also
be a COR grid if you take a finer grid
so this is the finer grid as you can see
here I have the same kernel I'm using
the same kernel because a kernel is uh
is exactly the same whether I have I'm
not resizing the kernel then let's do
the so I take these three values
remember that the orange here had three
very different values this values that
you're multiplying are exactly the same
right this is exactly the same values
but these three are very different from
these three and of course they're not
not identical and then when you slide
the window so for the next one which was
in red I take these three points again
they don't match the three points in the
red here and then for the green I take
these three points again they don't
match the three points on the green here
so you start making so the the
multipliers are exactly the same but the
point they are close to each other
because of course it's it's a signal on
the grid but they're not identical
because the the kernel is not going to
change it's exactly the same kernel so
algebraically you see that they cannot
be resolution dependent because the
values on different grids are exactly
completely different from each other so
because of that you cannot get this
answer here they are not not identical
to each other because of that it is not
the curent the convolution is such that
it cannot be Areno it cannot be
representation equivalent and this sort
of justifies what is happening here
right so if you remember I started out
with this picture so on a fixed grid
there you got whatever results but as
soon as you change grides you resized
your K you did not resize your konu but
you were multiplying the inputs and
outputs with different values so of
course you got different results and
these errors grew because of course each
time I slide the window I make a small
error but there are like five layers so
of course these errors accumulated they
might be small in the beginning but they
could accumulate exponentially in the
number of layers because of that you got
five times the error even though you
just resized the grid a little bit right
so this was sort of the effect of not
having this property you of having
aliasing errors so what we going what's
the solution then so we have to design
architectures we have to explore
architectures that reduce this error or
best eliminate them right so that would
be that would be the objective already
in the tutorial you saw saw one suchar
architecture which might have that
potential and this is what we're going
to do but only after how many days are
now we have a break next week right so
after in two weeks right so in two weeks
so you now you can you can rest for the
remaining two weeks so finish your
assignment good
okay see you in two weeks